wham-o the self-driving car company
owned by Google's parent company is
getting ready to roll out a fleet of
self-driving taxis those cabs will not
be entirely without human drivers even
if the driver is miles away Kris Van
Cleave is riding through Washington with
a Silicon Valley startups plan to come
to the rescue
when self-driving cars don't know what
to do Chris good morning
well good morning you know Nora before
too long we won't need anyone here
behind the steering wheel to drive this
vehicle but we've already seen examples
where the self-driving cars run into
situations where they can get confused
and have to stop like going through a
construction zone the one we're going
through right now is an example of that
this silicon-based company is hoping
that when the car needs to phone a
friend it'll be their technology that
puts a remote driver there to answer the
call and I will remote free that's right
I'll be monitoring your vehicle remotely
then shook Minar remote driver is a few
miles away in a Silicon Valley office
California is one of at least five
states allowing self-driving cars to be
on the road without a safety driver if
they have a system in place for a human
to take over remotely steering wheel is
moving car is moving if you're wondering
why an autonomous vehicle might need
somebody like a bend as the self-driving
technology advances we know that general
motors for example is going to build one
without a steering wheel without gas
pedals or brakes so if there was a
situation where the self-driving car had
to stop and didn't know what to do you
as the occupant couldn't do anything to
help you would need somebody to
intervene remotely phantom auto doesn't
build self-driving cars but they're
hoping their technology can come to the
rescue of a confused autonomous vehicle
it uses cell phone signals and cameras
already mounted to the vehicle so a
remote driver can take over in a
situation where the car doesn't know
what to do you're saying the ultimate
backup for the self-driving car is the
human yeah say you come to a
construction site and you have a
construction
or giving hand signals company flagging
traffic exactly exactly so the vehicle
may approach that construction site and
just completely be paralyzed at that
point the vehicle itself would ping a
phantom auto remote operator the remote
operator would be able to drive you
through the construction site in the
same way you could drive through a
construction site today way mode the
self driving company owned by Google's
parent alphabet is developing its own
assist technology Nissan is working on a
system where the autonomous vehicle
would stop and wait for a remote user to
draw it a map around an obstacle
phantoms technology allows the passenger
and remote driver to see and talk to
each other what a lot of people seeing
this are gonna wonder is what is it like
driving a car that you're nowhere near
go through a very strict training
procedure in order to learn how to
operate something completely new how do
you keep the car from getting hacked we
have a system in place where weak our
architecture can fit into the vehicle in
a way where we can override malicious
hacker federal regulations are stalled
in Congress leaving oversight largely to
the states some are stricter than others
the self-driving Ober crash that killed
a pedestrian in Arizona has prompted
states to take a second look at their
regulations as the technology is not yet
foolproof we can bridge the
technological gap from 99 percent to a
hundred percent by keeping a human in
the loop even after the uber crash you
think the technology is 98 99 percent
there the last 1 or 2 percent is a
really really difficult piece of the
puzzle to solve so it could be years
until the technology is at 100% you can
kind of think of the Phantom auto
service similar to OnStar a remote
helpdesk that would automatically
communicate with the car or with
passengers by a touch of a button you'd
have one remote driver acting as the
backup driver for several vehicles and
that would leave the backup plan for a
self-driving car firmly in the hands of
a human Gale ok I like anything with
humans I like OnStar listen try not to
sound like Nana at the table because I
know it's coming I just got to get just
got to get there
got again well you know I just want the
people that are working on it to really
be good at what they're doing and so far
you see people like that but you're like
everyone else you're used to having a
wheel or at least next to somebody who
has a wheel it gives you a sense of
control that's no small and I'm used to
an accelerator and a brake - yeah I like
that too
sir primal instincts there are so many
construction sites and stuff that is not
in the GPS you gotta get used to it
thank you Chris Van Cleve